i'm pleased to welcome greg pascarelli
back to hastings hall
greg was the in and to yale indeed uh
greg was the inaugural
louis icon visiting assistant professor
in spring 2004
and he returned
to yale in 2006's aero saarinen visiting
professor
tonight he will deliver the miriam
bellazoog memorial lecture
at the request of james anderchuk
christos bolos avi forman and marcus
addison hooks editors of perspective 47
money
all of them are class of 2 2012.
and i'm happy that to note that james
avi
and marcus are here christos has walked
off the reservation
he's in utah where is that
[Laughter]
the bella zoo lecture series was
established in 1999
honoring a 1991 graduate of the school
who was killed in 1996
when twa's flight 800
mysteriously crashed shortly after
taking off from new york on route to
paris it's now believed that that plane
was the first victim of a terrorist
bombing um although not 100 percent
certain
miriam was then editing what would have
been prospectus 70 a 30 rather
she was flying to paris as part of her
work in the office of the architect
peter mourinho who very generously
endowed
significantly to help this series get
started
as a as a memorial offering the editors
of the most recent perspective an
opportunity to invite a contributor to
their issue
to deliver a public lecture on an
original topic
greg pascarelli is the 17th bella zoo
lecturer
um and in the series and that began with
a talk by mark wigley
michael hayes kenneth frampton felicity
scott neil dinari
and sam jacob are among those who have
also been bella zoo lecturers
the most recent bella zoo lecturer was
sean kelly keller
assistant professor of architectural
history at the illinois institute of
technology
i first encountered greg pascarelli when
he was a student at columbia in the
early 1990s
where he arrived after receiving a
bachelor of science from the college of
commerce and finance at villanova
university
from our first encounter i realized that
greg was a force to be reckoned with
a young talent with a profound sense of
himself
and
and of new possibilities in architecture
not only in its relationship to craft
but also to commerce
after receiving his master of
architecture degree from colombia in
1994 greg worked in the office of
gregory form
before co-founding the firm's shop
sharples holden pascarelli in 1997.
shop quickly established itself as a
leader among the new generation of
architects garnering a number of
important commissions including the
atlantic yards project in brooklyn
and with projects in china kenya great
britain and throughout the united states
their pencil thin skyscraper apartment
tower
now on cons in construction on west 57th
street which i believe will get a
glimpse and explanation of
promises to be a notable new marker on
the manhattan skyline
in the year since uh uh since its
founding
shop has grown to a hundred percent 180
percent but i think i'm wrong what's
you're off by 50 because that was three
months ago three months ago 230 what you
know it's like it's like gaming theory
in las vegas
230 person practice located in lower
manhattan where their offices have the
privilege of overlooking the
construction of one of my buildings
[Laughter]
the firm's work has been exhibited
widely throughout the united states asia
south america and europe as well as in
the 200 2004 2006
and 2014 venice biennale uh our exhibits
in the uh uh
and
exhibits at the venice beyond only
shop was selected as an emerging voice
by the architectural league of new york
in 2001.
in 2002 wired magazine gave the firm the
rave award in architecture a citation
that celebrates innovation and the
individuals transforming commerce and
culture
the november 2002 issue of the magazine
a.d architecture and design
titled versioning evolutionary
techniques in architecture was guest
edited by shop
in 2014 shop architects was named the
most innovative architecture firm in the
world by fast company magazine and the
firm of the year by the new york state
chapter of the american institute of
architects please join me in welcoming
greg pascarelli back to yale as he
delivers the lecture design risk design
reward greg
[Applause]
thank you bob
it's great to be here
and um i really appreciate the kind
words and uh i do also remember our
first encounter at columbia and you were
very generous in the way you described
um
how full of myself i was
um it's wonderful to see so many old
friends here tonight it it's this i did
teach i think four times at yale under
dean stern's tenure
and every time it's been a fantastic
experience this is a really special
school
and
it always just feels good to come into
this building there's no question about
it
um
you know many thanks to the faculty who
are here tonight it's great to see so
many of you
and to the editors of perspective 47 and
most of all the students who came out
tonight so thank you very much
tonight i'll deliver a talk that is long
overdue but not easy to give
yes i will show the work of our office
shop and some of the projects that are
both familiar and not yet seen to try
and illustrate
our efforts
but there will be several parts of this
lecture that i have never discussed in
public before
partially because i was raised not to
discuss these things
partially and i was educated not to
discuss these things but we as a
profession must discuss
the central catalyst for most decisions
about designing and making our world
money and
risk
so shop was formed as a
as a firm that was really about a kind
of think tank that would ask questions
and that we would ask questions of each
other
and at shop we talk about money and risk
not in the sense of accumulation or
desire we talk about it in the sense
that one must be fluent in this language
if one wants to have an impact on how
most decisions are made
shop was formed as a collaborative
practice where questions of all kinds
are asked on a daily basis
whether or not they are cool or not
when bob asked me to give the talk i
started to think about the partnership
at shop the seven partners and 200
designers we thought about the number
seven in a few different ways
we started to think that seven as
partners is a number that keeps having
recurring themes both in architecture
and in outside of architecture
and we started to think about that idea
about what does seven mean what are the
things that you could do the lists of
seven go on and on and on
but the way we wanted to frame the
lecture tonight was about what we're
calling the seven rules tonight's
lecture will be about the rules that our
brilliant professors and our mentors and
our leaders have taught us and how we
broke them all
so there are seven rules that i'm going
to talk about that were things that were
just absolutely canonical in the way
that they were spoken to us about things
that you could and couldn't do to
succeed
and we didn't try to break them but it
just kind of happened and so i wanted to
frame tonight's lecture about risk and
money according to those seven rules
so the first one and actually bob i
think you and peter were the two told me
you said don't have more than two
partners at least with their names in
the in the in the name of not me
oh right you said only one i forgot
[Laughter]
so you know i think that a new
generation of practice thrives on the
notion that our lives and our firms are
intricate ecologies robust in some
regard and fragile in others much like
the world we are attempting attempting
to elucidate and improve
and so we have seven pop seven partners
at shop
and i think that
the most important thing is not that
there's just seven of us but that the
seven of us all came to architecture
from other backgrounds first
and that we were always kind of free to
adopt other means of problem solving
from other industries and try to bring
them into the world of design
i think that such offices represent
affiliations across multiple partners
with little but a vague understanding of
where the work of one individual begins
and the other ends
ironically the architectural blob that
once held hope as a third way beyond the
modern versus postmodern dichotomy has
unpredictably morphed the blob now has
sparked renewed optimism not necessarily
as an architectural form but rather as
the organization chart for new modes of
practice that may provide a way out of
the corporate versus celebrity trap
across the new firms
one sees common approaches but not
signatures in the work each may do for
institutions or developers for private
wealth or for public purpose while
clients and budgets may vary a core
creda we recite among ourselves binds us
together it's the complexity stupid
let's get together and try and solve the
problems
this is a map that i think came out
about three years ago which was the
first map that tried to completely draw
the universe now we know it's obviously
as wrong as a flat uh earth version of
the world at some point
but it's just an interesting thing that
that there's such an ability right now
to look at use technology to look at
data and to look at the complexities of
what what's happening in the world and
be able to see them in a way that we've
never been able to see them before
the the new millennium is exposed as to
a level of complexity heretofore
invisible to humanity era's past may
have been equally intricate but rarely
did we see the intricacy so clearly much
less revel in it
indeed how many of us could foresee the
overwhelming complexities with which we
are inundated today be it the internet
big data climate change fluid sexual and
racial identity the human genome
project late capitalism global pandemics
terrorism or rapid worldwide
urbanization we may simply want to nail
down our era but we have arrived at an
era that is simply too big to nail
this is a map that shows um i think it's
all the twitter feed the twitter
postings in
six different cities around the world in
a particular night bob notice the uh the
upper east side is very dark over here
as it should be
such shared such shared conviction may
well be the death knell of the lone
genius so revered since the
enlightenment as an anachronism
and this is a map this is the the latest
drawing of the internet i i find what's
interesting i think blue is is what's
the computer downloads that are coming
from north america
red is europe i think green is asia and
white are the unknown
nobody knows where they come from
and
what we are right now is in a moment
where we no longer need superman but we
need the avengers
we need the ability to have multiple
talented people come together for like
purpose to try and solve these
incredibly complex
problems
and so i mean i think our office has
always been about this from day one it
was about something that was shared and
and although as bob pointed out before
the name shop did originally come from
names of the partners sharp was sold in
pascarelli we actually took our names
off in the second year of our existence
and changed it just to shop
and it was really because we knew right
away that we wanted to practice in a
different way where it wasn't about one
particular person or name but it was
about this kind of group collective
where we could challenge each other and
challenge the way that architecture gets
built
so rule number two
don't build in your own city at least
not until you're good enough that you
can get away with it up close i believe
that it was frank lloyd wright that
first stated that and said that it's
really important to do it as far away as
you possibly can
um
you know but while shop does have work
around the globe and these are locations
of some of our projects
um we are definitely new york centric um
and have a lot of work going on in the
city
and while it's really exciting to travel
and to look take methods of problem
solving to different countries and to
think about how you might
solve those localized problems there's
something very different about working
in your hometown and it's something that
we love and we revel in and that we're
incredibly proud to be called new york
architects
so this is um a pic a drawing that was
recently done
of what the new york skyline will look
like in less than 10 years
um so the building that bob was talking
about that we're working on is uh is the
steinway tower right here i think that's
yours
a version a version a virgin
and we all know that's yours and about
20 others um
and um you know and the it's it's
amazing because we are we are in a
moment i believe that is going to be
written about just in the same way the
20s and 30s was written about we are at
a moment where new york is transforming
itself and doing it i think in wonderful
magical ways this started more than a
decade ago probably the catalyst was 911
in some in some respects but this idea
of the city and people living in dense
urban environments and the sustainable
strategies that that offers and and the
investment in design of public space to
keep quality of life high has really
fueled um the growth in in new york um
you know that building is announced but
there are three other towers shop is
working on that are all over 1200 feet
tall
um one in
in downtown brooklyn which will be the
tallest building in brooklyn one in
lower manhattan and another one in
midtown
and so while while it's
um it's tough to have to work out your
problems and your mistakes when you're a
young architect on home turf i also
think there's an incredible advantage to
it as well
so if alberti said that mathematics was
the common ground between art and
science we believe that those three
together are what create sort are are
the the the catalyst for good design
but that there's something else besides
design that that one has to as an
architect really embrace at multiple
levels and test out through your work
and so if local is this if building in
your home city and building locally is
the rule that we broke i think that the
way that we were able to break it was by
heavily involving ourselves in the
politics around space and and the way in
which buildings get built and approved
so i think the first time that we did
that successfully was with the east
river waterfront project which was an
international competition that we won to
do both a master plan and then a second
competition to actually design the
esplanade
that we also won
and quickly this is this is the map in
master planning and then the map in
schematic design of all the different
agencies
in new york that one would have to deal
with to get a publicly funded federally
funded and locally funded project
through two community boards seven
neighborhoods over 10 years and to be
able to be the master of the
of the the sort of coordination between
all of these elements really enabled the
architecture to uh to get a lot more
architecture approved and to build
something that was more robust and
something that actually has connected
with the local communities over time and
now as we embark on far more
controversial projects in these same
neighborhoods we actually have the
backing of the of the public in this
area because they knew that we came
through uh the first time
so the way that we started this was to
think about this esplanade as one
element of three parks surrounding a
harbor
we looked at the conditions
here you had
garbage and truck parking places where
there were up to 14 layers of fence
between where people lived in the
waterfront beautiful 18th century
squares used as parking lots and the way
in which we started to think about this
project was to look at all the different
neighborhoods and the problem was it was
very difficult to make what we called
the cross-grain connection from where
people lived out onto this waterfront to
use that open space
we did a survey of all the waterfront
typologies of new york to see what
worked and didn't work on each one
we found the places that were most
similar to the location that we were
working
and we started to think about the
conditions that we saw from a street
that was actually functioning at water
street to a service street uh pearl to
basically a highway and parking
lot area between the fdr and south
street to layers of fences to sheds on
piers blocking people from access to
open space
and so we made an argument to the city
get rid of the parking add as many trees
as you can wherever you could find soil
that opened up to the to the sky
get the bike lane in and while we did
try to take down the fdr drive in the
same way the embarcadero was taken down
we didn't have an earthquake to assist
us uh we got a lot of pushback from from
the banks in lower manhattan and so we
had to build a park with a elevated
highway going through it so we made the
argument instead of complaining about
this big object above us let's think of
it as a free roof and start to insert
different programmatic elements
underneath
underneath the highway and and use these
as ways to sort of activate the
waterfront
and then the other idea so here you see
the activated pavilions the fdr exists
we uh
narrowed the width of south street so
that you could cross it and then we
argued that you should try to make uh uh
both passive and active recreation on
the piers
and so the final design allowed for that
we we embedded the lighting inside the
drive itself so that you wouldn't have
big spotlights wherever we were on decks
we used precast concrete uh
elements that had also lighting buried
inside them that allowed us to mound up
the soil enough that we could get trees
we tried to put as many planters in
different locations
near the waterfront and then had other
places where the steps went right down
into the water and just by sort of
executing these planters dog runs
seating areas pavilions along what will
eventually be a 1.8 mile stretch of
esplanade it started to radically
transform the neighborhood in a very
positive way
and so the first phase was finished
about three years ago we're currently
working on phase two is under
construction phase three is also under
construction
and it was very simple
we convinced the city of new york to
allow us to paint the girder of the fdr
drive lavender that took two years
and
you have these what we call the get
downs that allow you to go down and
basically even touch the water the
plantings there are lights in the um in
the
railing system that shine out onto the
water and a series of furniture elements
and the other thing that was really
tough to get approved was we believe
that you should have bar seating at all
waterfronts because
because if you sit at a if you sit in a
standard chair and you look out to the
water the 42 inch rail is exactly where
your eye wants to see the horizon but
yet if you could make the railing become
wider and narrower where it necessarily
needed to be you could get these stools
up high when you sit there you could
have lunch you could read the paper and
you really get this fantastic view
so you can see this is almost exactly
where that truck and garbage pile was in
the first scene this is now a year after
the plantings have gone in here are some
of the get down elements where you can
go closer to the water
looking out from under the drive towards
brooklyn
and uh and walking along uh the
esplanade at night i have to say the the
lavender light is remarkably romantic i
guarantee you make out with whoever you
go down there with whenever you go
this is the first pavilion that finish
this will be a restaurant there's going
to be a series of up to 13 of these
along the two miles some will have
community facilities some recreational
facilities and some um some facilities
that will generate revenue such as this
one
just about to be open and then what has
been the most special part that we've
we've got to rebuild pier 15 which had
been taken down but they kept the
permits open and we're currently under
construction on pier 35.
and so
when we got there pier 15
as i said the permits were still open so
we could rebuild it um but we knew we
were able to do that but really we we
were so desperate for open space we
wanted to try and double the size of the
pier
now
there are environmental reasons why
people don't want you to shade more of
the river bottom
plus if you start to build the pier that
wide your biggest expense in the pier is
the piles going uh into the into the
riverbed
so our idea was to make a double decker
pier
and to use the the sort of revenue
producing um
a program to become green roofed uh
supports of the upper level of the deck
now the problem was are you just
recreating the problem of the fdr drive
with this big thing over your head so we
said well if you could make the belly of
the upper level so beautiful
therefore you kind of get two for one
two square feet of open space for every
foot of river that you're you're shading
and you eventually end up with a pier
that really works where you have active
maritime uses below revenue producing
pavilions here and then passive
recreation on the top and all made to
sort of feel a little bit magical by
having this sort of supple red roofed
underbelly
so here you can see the glass pavilions
that come right up through with their
green roofs that become lawns to sit on
there are planted elements there's
amphitheater seating looking at the
historic ships to this to the north
um here you can see it on a typical day
it's it's really
very well used
and then the feeling of being under it
uh at night
and so this was again the first phase as
it got completed very interesting
because we worked with with the public
agencies to get this built but meanwhile
right in the middle of the site was the
south street seaport which was under
lease to originally the rouse
corporation then general growth
properties and finally now the howard
hughes corporation
who then came to us and asked well what
would you do with this 1983 building
so which some of you may remember and
for those of you who've been down to new
york recently that's all gone right now
and so we said look there were a lot of
reasons why that building was designed
the way it was 30 years ago but i don't
think today we would do an interior
oriented
shopping complex on a waterfront that
didn't really connect to its its
surroundings so we said if you were
going to build something out there it
really needs to feel like streets and
and alleyways and places that you could
move through and that opened up the
views instantaneously to the peers of
the brooklyn bridge
and at the same time we felt that the
actual grid of the city needed to come
out that beekman street and fulton
street needed to come out to make a real
block we wanted to get the esplanade
through the neighborhood which wasn't
possible at the time and proposed then
putting pavilions and
the historic tin building would be
located here and then all of the far
from the entire site would be loaded
onto one site
to pay for the whole uh project
and so there is this kind of scale a
smaller scale of retail that we wanted
to bring out here we didn't want this to
be big box or typical shopping that you
could find anywhere else we wanted to
connect the parks through the esplanade
these series of different parks so it
almost makes a little bit of an emerald
necklace in the neighborhood
and looking at the existing uh site plan
with the proposed site plan that's
currently going through the euler
process today
and so one of the problems is that the
tin building is actually tucked under
the fdr drive but we've got to raise it
five feet to get it out of the flood
plain
the existing pure 17 building has been
removed
the tin building will be taken down and
cataloged the entire deck will be raised
five feet out of the hundred year flood
plain when it's rebuilt it will be set
back about 30 feet to allow the
esplanade to go through
the larger floor plates of pier 17 float
above and are sort of
wrapped in a highly articulated
channel glass facade
it's a flat roof which will then be
planted with a garden so it gives a 60
000 foot public open space to the
neighborhood
and then a series of retail pavilions
and buildings float underneath to make a
series of streets like a neighborhood
with double loaded retail on every
single part of the of the complex as it
moves out into the water
and so this was the existing
there's the big change
to the flat roof here
and that's been approved and now we're
working on this next portion
or phase of the work and one of the
things we really looked at the
morphology of the piers in new york uh
with these large-scale glass pier doors
that can drop up and down so it can
block the wind as it comes up and you've
got a series of different elements where
the water comes into the building the
building goes out to the water and you
have these streets and these are some
before and after shots
of what it looks like now with the
pavilions and the lighting system
underneath
and at night
this is what you see looking up where
you can't get the esplanade through
because it's blocked by these uh by
these retail buildings which will now
open all the way up and connect to to
the
cb3
here you see the tin historic tin
building which has been badly damaged
over the decades completely restored and
opened as a market
on the esplanade
the road looking through and making the
connection to to the ships below to the
south
and then the rooftop which could be used
for a multitude of different events
imagine being at a concert in front of
the brooklyn bridge you could see the
statue of liberty to the south we really
think it'll become a kind of iconic home
like bryant park or rockefeller center
for lower manhattan
so then the next question is
our rule is don't try to work with
developers too much you'll get in big
trouble you're sleeping with the enemy
you're gonna it's a slippery slope to
hell it's a really tricky process it's
you know your your ideas will be
compromised
and uh you know this is the classic the
classic line
do you want to stand alone against the
whole world there's no place for
originality and architecture
so that's from the fountainhead and um
but you know what the critical thing is
with with the next thing you need from
design is you need to engage in finance
as we talked about
and and the first time that we were ever
able to do that was with a building
called the porterhouse where we actually
found the site we negotiated an air
rights transfer we put the deal together
and we we
invested in the building to get it built
and some of you may know the building in
the meat packing district but again it
was this idea of the air rights transfer
cantilevering the building over the
historic buildings to the south getting
the cantilever out just far enough in a
very cost effective way that we were
able to predict additional revenue so
that we could outbid the other people
trying to get control of the property
and then to make this new building on
top where the idea that it shouldn't be
its idea of contextuality is that it
should look nothing like the building
that it's connected to
and so it was about an experimentation
of using of using zinc
and a
cnc production of that facade
um where we actually manufactured the
curtain wall ourselves um we went to
france we bought 4 000 sheets of zinc we
brought them back to new york we cut
them on a plasma cutter without any shop
drawings and put together label them the
architectural detail of the building
itself are the codes that are the
instructions set for putting it together
and very quickly the building went
together at a very cost effective
number and sold out for record prices at
the time in that neighborhood
and you know it was this kind of
connection between the old and new that
i think struck a chord with people the
kind of way that we were able to get
three exposures on each side move the
cord to the center that became our
structural element that keeps the
building from tipping over
and and one of my favorite pieces of
this is the kind of depth i think one of
the reasons the metal building works so
well is that the the windows are placed
14 inches behind the the metal facade
where if we weren't the developer
there's no way we would have gotten to
do that they would have been seen as too
much of a waste of space
the other problem with it is by pushing
them back you end up with ledges that
creates a pigeon problem
on your building but we
actually called the museum in natural
history they told us if we made a 33
degree angle a pigeon will land on it
and slide off
and and uh 12 years after we've gotten
this building done there's not one bird
[ __ ] on the entire facade
the building lights up at night as
really becomes an anchor for what was
then not really the meat packing
district as we know it today
but it was very different we did the
collateral materials we brought it to
market
and and here's how the and wonderfully
the building won as many design awards
as it won preservation awards and that
to us was really kind of a wonderful
thing
but
there's this notion of design risk
design reward and the thing that we
learned from that project was that
we were we you know literally a lot of
the people that we talked with said you
know this is a really dangerous thing
you're doing you know you guys have some
pretty good street cred if you guys get
in bed with the development community
you know you might lose that and and
there was this really interesting thing
you're going to be beholden to them in a
way that you couldn't what we found out
was exactly the opposite was true as
soon as we were at risk with our client
in the same way we suddenly had more
design freedom than we ever had before
because they saw the relationship in a
completely different way
at the same time so risk we started to
see is a good thing
and when we started to look at things we
we noticed that you know
basically the less risk you take the
lower your profit margins are and the
more risk you take the higher they have
to be one because you're going to lose
every once in a while that will bring
things a little bit back to to
equilibrium but it's also when you're
taking risk and inventing something and
doing something that's very successful
you're rewarded for it and so when you
look at different industries it's pretty
interesting to see how low architects
typical profit margin are compared to a
lot of other industries
but even within the building industry
it's still pretty low and it's a lot
because of labor costs it's a lot
because of the cost of chasing work
there are a lot of reasons why
why we do it but one of the main reasons
is as a profession we don't take risk
the aia has tried to teach us for the
past 40 or 50 years that risk is bad and
that you should not get involved in all
the other things that help make a
building keep it keep it at arm's length
and and you know that's the that's the
best strategy and we're not so sure if
that's true and there is a profitability
lag between architecture engineering and
related services and other professional
scientific and technical services and
what is that why is that and shouldn't
that change and what do we need to do
about it another thing is when you're
running a firm when you do your first
project of a type you're sort of steep
on the learning curve this is probably
even an aggressive number you're lucky
if you even break even on the first one
of a type that you do but over time that
goes up and then of course it levels out
but the problem is you don't want to be
in one single type of do one single type
of project because all project types go
through cycles and if you put all your
eggs in one basket when that when that
industry goes down
you get wiped out
and so the goal is to constantly think
about the balance between that profit
margin and and diversifying your work
among as many sectors as possible so
that you can keep the firm in a healthy
place and have more ability to think
about what you want to invest in what
you want to do research in to
continually push architecture forward
but at the end of the day what value do
you create what do you really create for
your clients
and you know if you do really create
value are you just a service are you
something that they could buy anywhere
or are you something that actually gives
them gives them value and can you can
you actually quantify that value and if
you if you can then i think we have to
rethink the way in which we work as
architects in this industry
now i'm i'm going to go a little bit
into the way deals are structured and
basically and there's believe me for
every kind of deal you know there's a
million different ways to structure a
deal this is a very sort of typical
straight-up way of thinking about it but
basically the general partners are the
people that find the site put the deal
together think about it lead the lead
the lead the aesthetic and the branding
ideas and do the work all day long and
the limited partners are the people that
help them by giving them capital to do
that work with
and so what are the metrics on a typical
deal
so the way one can think about it is and
these are very broad round numbers just
to keep it simple
so let's just say you had a hundred
thousand square foot buildable site
and let's say you for that land you have
to pay five hundred dollars a buildable
foot so that's 50 million dollars to buy
the property
let's say from that you're gonna have
about a hundred and ten thousand square
feet of construction because you have
basements you have mechanical spaces
it's a little bit more than what the
zoning allows and let's say you're
building that at four hundred dollars a
square foot
and then your soft costs for running all
of that are usually about thirty percent
of those two numbers put together
so that gives you a hundred and twenty
two million dollar project cost
now what you can get on 122 if you can
prove that you are um that your numbers
work and you can show the lender there
are comparable properties in this
neighborhood with this typology that
were built for this much and sold for
this much and you've got about a 30
uh projected profit amount they will
loan you about 65
of the of the
amount of the deal so that's your senior
debt which comes in at your lowest
interest rate and then you go after
something called a mezzanine loan
because they're second in the payout so
they charge you a little bit more
and you're basically need about 20
million in cash to do that project
now what's typically required it's not
required it's whatever the developer's
reputation can let them get away with
but often they want to they want the
developer
himself to put in about 20 of that cash
or about 4 million dollars
and then that means he needs to raise 16
million dollars from the limited
partners and that means the project is
completely funded so that's the cost
side so what happens on the revenue side
you've got about 110 100 000 foot zoning
building you've end up with about 85 000
square feet net sellable let's just say
for argument's sake you sell it at 1900
a square foot
that's 161 million
your sales commission to the brokers is
going to be about a million dollars
the paying back the senior debt that
you've had for that time plus the
interest is 88 million and that 8
million additional and those
additional interest payments that's why
your clients yell at you to go as fast
as possible because the the meter is
ticking
the mezzanine debt gets paid back
roughly would be about 28 million the
value the the developers investment gets
paid back with interest the limited
partners get paid back from their um
investment with interest
the developer takes a fee which runs is
overhead and is because they are who
they are and can and have the sort of
guts to do this
and the net profit at the end of the day
is somewhere around 15 million 500 000
and that gets split 50 50 between the
limited partners and the general
partners
so that's basically how a deal how a
deal works now in this whole deal the
architect would have been paid let's say
they were getting fifteen dollars a
square foot on a hundred thousand
building a million and a half dollars
and their cost is probably somewhere
around a million two
so for doing almost more work than
anyone in this entire project their net
profit is three hundred thousand dollars
think about that
so
the question is
if you think you're good and you believe
in the project why don't you invest your
architecture fee of a million and a half
dollars
up front why don't you say we'll fund
this out of our pocket but every one of
those dollars goes in just the way it
goes in
as you as you mister developer and you
mr
limited uh partner
and in fact because we're going to help
you think through this whole project
we're going to take a piece of the
general partnership and our million and
a half is going to go into the limited
side as well
and the developer off sometimes doesn't
like this but often does like it because
their hardest dollar that they have to
spend is the money up front before
they've got their bank loan in place and
who's the first person they spend money
on the architect because they need a
drawing and a vision to even go to the
bank to get the loan at the first place
so they're thrilled not to have to spend
that money up front
so let's just say we invested the
million and a half as a as a profession
or as a as an architect with these guys
you get your million and a half
investment back
you get 240 000 limited partner interest
you get 600 000 limited partner
distribution
you get if you had 10 of the general
partnership and that would be a
reasonable amount for this amount of
work you'd get 775
from the general partner distribution
which means now your fee for that
project is about
3.1 million so you've doubled the fee
and you're going from a 13 profit margin
to 108 percent profit margin
but now let's talk about sensitivity
let's say the market turns south that
return goes down and you have you you're
at risk right but what if you're really
good
what if you're the kind of architect
that can produce a 15 central park west
and watch
and and and watch the numbers go up
right but now now if you really think
that what you can do is so good that
it's going to drive sales it's going to
make it sell out faster it's going to
sell at higher numbers watch what
happens if you could just get the number
to go up 10
10 percent more in sales would give you
another 1.4 million dollars out of the
project which now your profit margin has
gone to 201
there is some data out there and we've
put a lot of these metrics together that
the difference between a very well-known
architect who's very very skilled and a
basic building often results in about an
average of 17 to 20 additional revenue
for the developer
if you go to 20 more in your sales
you're talking about an additional 2.8
million dollars a fee suddenly you're in
the 294 profit margin suddenly you can
now take that money and and invest in
your firm you can invest in your people
you can do research you could do shows
you could do competitions you can invest
in technology you've got a much better
chance
for the for the amount of intelligence
that we put into these projects there's
no reason why we shouldn't be at risk
not on all of them can't do this on
libraries
can't do this you know you can't can't
do this in university buildings but why
don't why don't we as a profession joint
venture with these with these guys and
be at risk with them and you know what
so let's say maybe two out of three work
out and one out of three fails you're
still going to be way ahead of the game
and and i believe that when you do this
you're going to get more design freedom
you are going to get to be more risky
with the ideas that you're testing out
but you're going to test them out in a
really intelligent way that helps you to
drive the sales and drive the
profitability and so i've been always
sort of saying it's kind of like
newton's third law the more you go in
one direction into the sort of technical
and financial and political side of
things you actually get the freedom to
go in the exact opposite direction
to push design ideas and make things
happen
now in the last 10 years we've probably
done about six deals like this
and four of them went well one of them
went badly one of them went horribly
badly right
even if at the end of the day and i
don't even know if this is true but
let's say we broke even maybe we did
it was still an amazing idea because we
got six projects that we got to test out
ideas that helped us win bigger and
bigger work over time
that allowed us to that allowed us to
sort of experiment and work
and work in different ways that we
wouldn't have if we didn't take that
risk
so
on another project that we've been
working on is the domino sugar plant
project so really at a critical junction
in the river
where you get amazing views to midtown
and to lower manhattan
it's a quarter mile long 11-acre site
and the original plan that had gone
through euler had a series of
contextually scaled buildings
uh that all ended in cul-de-sacs with
stairs down to a park with the buildings
facing directly onto the park
and our client came to us and said
tell us we're crazy and we should not go
through the approvals process a second
time
and so we said well if if this were our
site
we would probably try and extend the
street along the front so that you
create a true public park we would bring
the grid of the city through and connect
it and really make it part of the fabric
of the city more along the lines of what
riverside drive is
and then we would take this building out
since you own this site as well move all
the far to the other sites and create a
kind of urban public square at this
location
and so the idea was instead of having
this sort of wall of lumpy buildings all
the same size
let's push them back
let's make them taller
let's put holes in them so that light
can get through
let's bring the street through and let's
make two kinds of park uh that one
that's sort of more on the urban scale
and one on the scale of the river
and let's break the buildings down with
different setbacks and public roof
terraces first at the scale of the
low-rise industrial neighbors behind
another step at the sort of scale of the
williamsburg bridge and the domino sugar
factory and a third one as a marker on
the skyline
and so we went back to the community and
this does not happen very often but got
almost unanimous approval to increase
the height of our buildings by 50
percent
and and an extra half a million square
feet of far because of the design and
they said and we said you know we're
showing designs but these are just
zoning diagrams this is not what the
buildings will look like and they said
well we want written into the zoning
guidelines that they have these giant
holes in them
when they go through which we did
and so and of course the holes really
this is just two slab buildings 65 by
you know 150 foot slabs the only tricky
part is the little bridge five-story
bridge that connects up connects the two
otherwise these are super standard
buildings if you will same thing on
on site four
and so you kind of get you know a low
rise with a building that comes up and
the bridge element
same thing on the high rise
and and again these are all placeholder
uh facades because uh we also said that
we would not take this project if shop
were to design all five of them we
didn't want to be in a place that was
all shop uh we are going to take this
one which because it's first and we're
gonna take this one because we think
it's the coolest
but um this one and this one and this
one are all going to go to other
architects and we're very excited about
this and james corner is doing all of
our landscape from field ops
and again it's remarkable much more open
space
jim's doing an amazing job on on the
park where we're actually taking the
refinery elements out
here you can see
the building it's a much more mixed-use
development
no big box stores whatsoever designed
specifically that they can't be
accommodated
no poor door some of you been reading
about the poor doors that are happening
lately so we just don't believe in that
we don't think it's right
and then also some of the zoning on the
williamsburg waterfront in the long
island city waterfront it's got the same
height all along like 350 feet i don't
understand why that people think that
makes a good city that everything is the
same height
because you know um uh
as as many of us refer to looking at the
skyline of new york is the same
excitement when dorothy saw oz for the
first time it's about that difference
imagine if we had that ridiculous kind
of zoning cap that's what new york would
look like
right that's miserable we don't want
that
so the idea is instead of a monotonous
wall
let's get a sort of new waterfront
skyline
and and get those buildings through and
and it passed it passed and it's under
construction right now
another another rule is don't be nice
this idea that there's an important
social responsibility required in
architecture
and that it isn't about the individual
in the cubicle working like a machine
producing drawing sets
there are some very well-known
architects who use this formula to get
around labor laws
in the united states where you get paid
an annual salary of sixteen thousand or
seventeen thousand dollars a year
because they can make an argument that
that equates uh to being paid minimum
wage
and we don't believe that we think that
that's that's a terrible idea that it's
really about how you treat your people
that matters
um we've never had an unpaid intern in
the history of our office not even day
one when when it was the five of us
with no money every single employee has
to have full health insurance
mostly paid by us
every designer has access to the
partners
we will not work for dictators we will
not work in in countries where
indentured servitude is used to build
the buildings we just think that's
fundamentally wrong and not what we
should be doing as a profession
and whenever we go to another country we
try to do set up as much knowledge
transfer as possible
so
we work for another company that says
they don't do evil
and um worked on a very interesting
project with them where they wanted a
building that was beyond lead platinum
was that was the assignment for a 350
000 foot
uh technology building and so it was
this idea of a kind of um
roof that held all the technology and
then there were gardens that were sunk
into it
um and we wrote our own software our own
scripts that showed the founders that if
they changed the priorities of what the
building was going to do it literally
changed the morphology of the building
itself
and it was about neighborhoods and the
way in which one would occupy their
spaces to sort of get their uh their
their engineers talking and thinking
with each other and so we thought about
the building on scales different scales
like the super highway how you move from
different departments to the sort of
main street where there were smaller
elements down to the kind of medieval
streets where where different groups
were working on separate softwares
it generated this form
here was the model of the building
and uh it was we were very excited to
get started
and then the global financial crisis hit
um and they put the building on hold i
mentioned to them that i had read that
they had 17 billion in cash on their
balance sheet but that didn't uh they
didn't want to be seen building a
building like that at that time
so went on hold so now we had a bunch of
people with not a lot to do as the
crisis hit
so there was an international
competition to do an innovation hub in
botswana africa
and so we took um
we took we took google
and we where the sun is in the south and
we flipped it to botswana africa
where the sun was in the north
and took the same idea and took the
different climate conditions and the
different programmatic relationships
that were needed for an innovation hub
and so we took this idea of the dune and
delta the two uh sort of major landform
elements in botswana
and made a a similar kind of building
with a series of bars that could be
phased over time that were connected but
one of the wonderful things were these
incredible 150 year old trees all over
the site that they told us we could
clear but we said instead just build the
parking the parking needs to be shaded
in in botswana because the sun's too hot
so we said we'll just burn the property
up we'll put the parking on grade
the new sort of first floor of the
building will be burned up a floor and
we'll cut holes and let the trees come
up through
through from the parking to create the
parking below to create these shading
areas inside these uh
courtyards
and so
we won the competition
and have gone down and set up education
programs in the architecture school have
been going back and forth and the
project is under construction right now
should be finished in about 14 months or
15 months from now
incredible
[Music]
scripting for parametric design for the
roof systems this will be the largest
green roof in africa
even though it'll be brown 10 months out
of the year
we took traditional
local basket weaving techniques and
wrote scripts
to develop different kinds of wall
systems for the public spaces they're
making it out of harvested wood
down there they've got the cnc machines
in gaborone making the pieces
so these become the kind of in the
double and triple height spaces the way
that the surfaces get done these were
the prototypes of the wood wall elements
and then what these will look like
they'll have the mechanical and
ventilation and lighting systems behind
them
and will create these interior spaces
whoops sorry here are the the more
recent uh
images
and the entry
the roof
and the building as it will sit in the
landscape
so it's been an amazing experience to
work
to work on this uh on this project
rule five don't talk about beauty
so you know this idea about um about
design and theory and talking about
beauty you know his trick is tricky
right because we're taught not to really
talk about it
but humans need beauty as much as we
need air water song particularly when it
is understood as the fingerprint of
human action in the anonymous vastness
of our times
and i think i'm going to skip through
ps1 you guys have all seen it just i
want to make sure we get there fast
but um we're currently working on a
project that we can't tell you what
country or city it's in or who the who
the client is but it's it's a really
interesting project
because it's it's three institutions and
a kunst hall coming together
with a financial driver of a development
building on top and not one of the con
not any one of the four main elements
can have the primary
uh spot they all have to be equal and so
the idea was to take four sort of silos
of arts institutions twist them around
each other cut them according to the to
the box of the site and then find a
place that you might be able to go up in
the future um with a tower and to think
about the street level uh with different
kinds of elements music and market
shopping and then sort of big social
gathering space
and then how the building has a giant
sort of public urban living room facing
one of the main corners of the city with
an operable window that opens up and and
can open and close depending on the
weather with a large amphitheater facing
this public space
and as the space moves up
each one each one of the institutions
has its own
zone and you can go in glass bridges a
la grand central station between those
elements and then wherever the markers
for the the sort of campus uh lines of
desire on the ground floor become the
slots between the different institutions
to mark the entries on the facade
and
this was the hardest model we ever built
you could see it going together
and then this is the proposed project
which won the competition and that we're
working on right now
but you can really see
the into these kind of
incredible section spaces between
the institutions and then the grand
urban room and then the entry and the
base to what will eventually be a tower
on top
um this is basically a kind of ceramic
rain screen
with glass this whole part has multiple
theaters on this section so the theaters
actually occupy
the sloping
floor
and some looks inside the building these
are of course very early renderings
but um really an exciting project to
take so many of the things that we've
done and now address them to a cultural
institution and to really just try and
think about a building that's both
beautiful and functional at the same
time
don't get involved in means and methods
two more projects and we're done
um
literally every contract tells you not
to get involved in means and methods and
yet i think from day one we've always
felt that if you're going to get these
buildings built if you're going to take
risks and try and push the envelope of
what you could do you better damn well
know how that building goes together or
it's going to get vet out as soon as
possible and so from the day one we've
always really tried to think
before we make a shape or a form how is
that going to be made what's the
material how is it going to be put
together how do you clamp it what's the
expensive way of putting it together and
what's the less expensive way and if the
less expensive way we can make just as
beautiful go with that right away we'll
have a better chance of getting it done
and you know that's technology you know
that's really getting involved in that
and it's the use of technology to
celebrate humanity
not the use of technology to celebrate
technology
that's a big critical difference
and the time where i think i mean i
think we've been doing this since ps1
but when the time we got to execute it
on the biggest scale was at barclay
center
where there if we did not actually joint
venture with the facade manufacturer and
the contractor there's no way we get
that facade built
and as some of you know this was a long
process that started with with frank
gehry and his brilliant plan for an
urban arena that was surrounded by four
towers that had basically big
foundations that held a bowl in the
middle
now when the economy went south they all
said the arena was too expensive the
arena was not too expensive the arena
was a billion dollars to begin with and
it was a billion dollars when it got
finished what was the problem was that
in 2009 you could not finance any of the
four towers that were holding up the
arena
they there was no one was giving loans
on them so they had to redesign the
whole building
which bruce ratner loved frank and loves
all the work that he's done with them
and it's a really smart idea for an
urban arena the problem was if the
foundations weren't in the ground by
december 31st 2009
that was when tax stadium tax bond
stadium bond financing was no longer tax
deductible and that would have been a
400 million dollar hit to the project
so they had to redesign the project and
get it in the ground this was now may of
2009
so they went to the biggest design build
contractor of nba arenas
which was hunt construction they said
how do we get in the ground in seven
months they said you have to go to an
arena that we've already built
see that it fits on the site we have the
steel drawings already done we can order
the steel tomorrow and maybe we can get
you in
so that's what they did
and they picked an ellerbe beckett
building from indianapolis it fit on the
site and it was really unfair to
elaborate beckett because they were told
to just do that
it caused a few problems in the city of
new york when everyone felt they were
going to get a frank gehry building and
instead they didn't
and then they asked us to come in and
see if we could take take the existing
steel take it apart as much as we could
and then rebuild it again and completely
change what the building would look like
which was not easy and oh they gave us
seven weeks to do that um
including designing it detailing it and
costing it and we had a delta of 40
million max or we were fired
so what we said was that we had to think
about this building
as it related to people walking on the
street because we wanted it to be a good
neighbor
we wanted to have one band of the
building that related to the sort of
brownstone height
in in brooklyn
and then another sort of element or band
above that was something that could be
red on the skyline
and so this was the idea would take it
from a horizontal building to i'm sorry
from a vertical building to a horizontal
building
align the sidewalk with the concourses
so there was constantly views in and out
and then make this sort of grand civic
gesture um as we've sort of jokingly
called it the arms of bernini but
hip-hop style for brooklyn
so
um and then the other thing is that
there was not one parking spot built for
this arena not one and so we said that
this should be the first arena certainly
in the united states that prioritizes
those who come by public transportation
over those who come by private
transportation and so we worked on this
subway station that when you come up out
of it you look up through this oculus of
the sort of arms of bernini if you will
at the upper halo and then opened up the
building and took away a huge amount of
the seating so that when you first come
in you can see all the way to the bowl
and to the scoreboard
we had to model this entire building it
was 12 000 different shaped panels of
core 10 steel
we produced all the fabrication tickets
we helped them set up a factory to
weather the steel they went through 15
wet dry cycles a day for four months to
put 10 years of patina on them
we tagged every single one and wrote
wrote the codes for them we wrote an
iphone software app that you could go up
and scan any panel at any time so that
everyone from bruce ratner to a guy with
a wrench had the same exact information
and knew exactly how the building was
going together at that time and that
transparency is what changed everything
on the pricing of the building they were
made into 921 mega panels
delivered to the site and they all fit
you can see the building as it sits
today
and then we got them to put the digital
boards on the inside ring of the oculus
so it wouldn't blare out into the
neighborhood and really creates this
incredible sort of public space as you
come to the building and the interiors
with the idea of the kind of wet
brooklyn night i know this is driving
you crazy bob talking about brooklyn so
much right
so better you than me
the ribs the ribs come in from the
outside that hold up the the facade and
create these lighting elements there are
sort of these minimalist boxes that pop
in with all brooklyn um uh food vendors
um some places where the materials
change to get warmer
um we went back to ps1 for the for the
bar carts the beer carts which was
really fun to do
and um we not only convinced them to
make all this all the seats black
because we felt it wanted to be like
black box theater that sports sports of
this is this great uh entertainment that
has an unscripted ending and so we
wanted to be more dramatic more
theatrical and um and help convince the
team to change their colors from red
white and blue to black and white
my dumbest business career move of my
life was not figuring out a way to
profit from that because they went from
26th in sales in the league to fifth in
sales in the league in one year probably
worth 50 to 60 million dollars
and finally the last project and the
last rule don't try to do it all
and you know what we try to do is think
about is think about we have a lot of
smart creative people in the office what
are the other things we can do what are
the problems that architects are facing
all the time what should we test out
and so
we've just currently develop we're
developing the software we're actually
in our venture capital fundraising right
now it's all been funded in-house but
now we're going to bring it commercially
and this is an example of a software
you click that that we've developed
called envelopes this is a little
animation and what you can do is you can
look up any site
you can select the site it will give you
all the zoning information it will tell
you what you can do you click on these
buttons
it tells you all the bonuses that you
can have all the rules and within 60
seconds we'll mask your building for you
and you not only outputs it to your to
your spreadsheet for your financial
analysis it also outputs it to revit so
you can start designing
you can you can click through and change
the floor to floor heights you watch the
building literally morph in the zoning
code and if you make a decision that
leaves any square feet on the table uh
it will let you know and let your client
know as well so it's an amazing thing
that's something that takes a good
architect and a zoning uh lawyer you
know six hours to do
uh at extreme you know at extremely high
rates this is now a product that can do
it for you online in under 60 seconds
and we think it's something that not
only will help architects and and zoning
attorneys and developers but we actually
think in the same way that lotus 123 in
excel when spreadsheets came out in the
80s that's when mergers and acquisitions
went up on wall street because suddenly
people could look at information in a
completely different way understand
sensitivity analysis and therefore were
more willing to make the deals we
believe software like this will actually
make all of us get more commissions in
the future
so again
what we really believe is that
the the parts of this model are what
come back together to to create
architecture and that it's doing all of
those elements and and getting your your
hands dirty in all the different parts
to really make it come together
and so the last building that i'm going
to show you is our project on 57th
street
you know again this idea of the sort of
low
new york fabric and then the soaring
tower was an inspiration to us and we
thought about what are the buildings
that new yorkers love the most
um and why do we love them and i think
one of the reasons we love them is their
proportion
and that they they have these were all
office buildings
obviously but they have this incredible
proportion this detail of the setback
and this kind of rich use of material
that plays with shadow and light and
that these slender towers are are just
they look good
um and they they used to sit above the
low rise of of the city itself
but of course with air conditioning and
different kinds of corporate structures
the bigger floor plate became the more
desirable floor plate and the buildings
became much more massive and suddenly
sat on the skyline like this
but as i said before i think we're in a
remarkable time because now the cost of
some of these prime residential
spaces has gone up so much that it
actually makes it um uh
possible to build super tall for
residential
and so now you've got a series of six or
seven super tall buildings going up
mostly along the 57th street corridor
that are going to almost bring back that
golden age of the new york skyscraper
and and they range in sizes and some and
ours is actually the the skinniest of
all of them at only 60 by 80 feet
um
432 park is 80 by 80 or 80 by 90.
um and then the the site that we had was
steinway hall
uh our client actually had the interior
landmark it's worn in wetmore building
um and home to steinway piano since the
1920s
and the way that we the way that we got
this approved because the only other and
i think this or the only other tower
that's been put on a landmark building
is hearst is that correct it's super
tall tower
um because yeah it's pretty much i think
it's the only one so we're doing one on
60th that cantilever's over cantilever
it doesn't actually sit no right
that's right right
so the as of right scheme
actually allowed us to build the
building right up against the landmark
and kind of obliterate the whole side
and so what we argued to landmarks was
let us push it back we'll fulfill the
85-foot high street wall requirement
with with a retail base but let us
celebrate the beautiful part of the
building but we're going to have to
build a little bit on top of the
building back
in in in sort of the corner
and then in order to get the first
apartment to have the views over the
buildings
to the north of it onto the park this
will literally be built as a 21 story
atrium with nothing in it to push all of
the far up above
and so here you could see
the kind of base and how it integrates
with the historic building this whole
wall
uh there used to be a two-story the ritz
thrift shop used to be there so that all
that limestone was gone so we're going
to restore that wall as if it was always
exposed you'll be able to see it from
the side
and um and then you've got the plan with
the historic building here we're using
the old loading docks for the steinway
pianos into a new port cochair and bob
you can write it down now i never
thought i'd draw an ellipse in a plan in
my entire life
and and if there was i never thought i'd
get you to do one
and if there ever was a slippery slope
to hell i think i just went
it's gonna be the making of you
um and so then you you really now see
the landmark as it turns the the bronze
facade comes down and drops as this kind
of minimalist retail facade
and then we looked at the idea of the
setback the famous hugh ferris drawings
and we said okay this is our zoning
envelope this would be the way the
setback would normally be done but what
if we hyper articulated the setback and
did almost what we call the feathered
setback
um and what if we thought about the plan
because it's dead center on the park
where you kind of have the park view and
the city view as you come off the
elevator
we thought of it as the sort of living
to the north and the sleeping to the
south
and uh the plans
and structurally the building is
basically two monster shear walls on the
east and west where you have the least
amount of view they are punctured a
little bit for some of your service
rooms but really it's almost solid on
both sides and that's the way we're
getting it to stand up so we said how
would we articulate that facade and
again went back to what are our favorite
buildings in new york from a certain
period
and we said well what if we use
traditional materials but in a super
contemporary way
and what if we made each single setback
a plaster in and of itself
and then took the pattern from the
setback and took the material which is
going to be terracotta and bronze and
made 21 different shapes of the
terracotta so that it twists back and
forth as you go up the facade so that
when the light comes from the south
it'll cast these shadows in the
thickness of the facade itself
and so here
who knew we could use a french curve so
here's a french curve
and here are the different 21 layers and
then as they move up and down they
create these uh shadows on the facade
itself you can see and the models these
are the full-scale mock-ups the the
terracotta cantilevers 21 inches off the
facade so it will be legible
as you go up and then it's got a bronze
filigree that's sort of a sinewy tissue
pulling apart the elements that then
have both the shear wall and
the glass windows behind them on the
east and west facades
and looking east on 57th street you'll
get this kind of incredible
reading of the materiality and the idea
of the new york building but very much a
21st century version of it
the park view is almost all glass
with again a bronze reveal
the windows get wider towards the middle
and narrower out towards the end
so that's really your 60-foot living
space facing the park dead center
and the city view has vertical uh bronze
fins
running up and down the building and
then creates the sort of setback
terraces as you go up
and yes sophia loren has bought an
apartment so
um the building is uh 1400 feet tall
and 60 feet by 80 feet wide which will
make it the most slender building in the
world
at 24 and a half to one slenderness
ratio
and then at night
the last apartment is about here then
you have the tuned mass damper and then
really the top 200 feet is just a glass
and bronze
sculpture or night light if you will
um on the sky skyline and working with
observatoire
inside the terracotta are soft lights
that will reflect off the bronze itself
so in the day you'll really read the
terracotta and at night you'll read the
bronze
and the building's sitting
on 57th street
so those are the seven rules
um
it's been really fun to think about them
it's been fun to um you know to to
think about architecture and some of the
things that really matter to our firm
and to talk to you about it tonight
i mean i think this is an incredible
incredible time to be a young architect
you know the technology is making
complexity apparent and allowing us to
challenge the status quo at every turn
there's paradigm shifts that are
allowing us to think as architects and
operate in different ways that maybe we
never had the ability to do before
i've said this before i think that
architecture is the last great
generalist profession that what we're so
good at is that we're so good at many
many things but yet somehow i think as a
profession we've lost our way and we've
tried to think narrowly in just terms of
aesthetics and have given up on the
politics or the finance or the
technology or all the things that made
us master builders
you know throughout the 20th century
most schools of architecture enforce the
notion that collaboration was a path
towards mediocrity and was therefore the
sole concern of multi-headed corporate
firms
but with the advent of a new millennium
a younger generation of practitioners
and educators are intensely
experimenting with new modes of
collaboration
and these new modes of collaboration
embody the complexity of the problems we
are trying to solve today
by acting upon the ferocity of our
convictions we seek to recast the role
of architects as as we who reveal the
coherence in our chaos we who through
our collective imprint expose the
lurking beauty in the bedlam of our
world
i am proud to be an architect
i believe we can make a huge difference
and we have but we have to prove that
newton was correct and have equal and
opposite reactions we need to be both
and
we need to take the risks we need to
take the chance we need to break the
rules and i think we can have an
incredible time with our lives doing it
and make the world a better place thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you craig shop the method shop the
um
the the um the the the the product uh
that was just great
i'm sure there are a few questions will
you take them i'm happy to take some
questions questions for greg pascarelli
uh brandon buck can we get a mic to you
is it working
sorry i
i didn't see you sorry uh so in all of
the
developers
lectures year after year i've never
heard them
talk about money and so it's great to
see hear about the back end and make
that explicit
thomas piketty's capital of 21st century
is sort of about capital becoming more
valuable than labor and so the clever
thing that you're doing there is turning
labor in a sense into capital and
um
i guess the question would be
as architects
that seems good for us we're also
trained to be
not just a service profession but also
you know civic duty challenge the public
our you have inhabitants of our
buildings
when architects have
that much of a profit margin is there
any concerns we should have about
architecture and the sort of outcome
design wise civic wise et cetera um no
no i actually think the opposite if
we're not struggling and killing
ourselves to pay the rent every single
month you'd actually might spend more
time designing
i mean it's you know and i think that um
look
you know that was a comp those metrics
that i showed were a complete
hypothetical example and for every win
that you have you have lost you there
are losses as well so
at the end of the day
it's never going to be a 200 profit
margin you're going to have some losses
that bring you back but let's not
operate at 13
anymore i mean that's ridiculous for
what we contribute but it's all we
deserve because we don't take the risk
so all and again also when you're doing
you know well maybe at a presidential
library you get a bigger fee but in like
regular libraries or regular
regular buildings maybe on other jobs
too
you know you um
you're not you know when you're doing a
park you're not gonna take you're not
gonna get a piece of the action of the
park right so even if this is
10 or 20 percent of the work that you're
doing and if you can do well on two out
of three
you know it's not going to make you
suddenly
making the same amount of money as you
know larry silverstein or steve ross
it's it's what we're just saying is
take the risk and then use that capital
to help you do a better job to to make a
better culture in your office to
experiment with all more forms to think
about uh the impact that you have as
opposed to that sort of daily brutal
struggle which quite frankly it is the
practice of architecture is but it's
self-made
we have that question in the back
hi
um you talked about the ferocity of your
convictions i'm sorry i couldn't hear
you you talked about the ferocity of
your convictions
i'm interested to know when did they
form and
what's the background did you always
have them or when you think that's the
north on the way up here
no um you know quite frankly
um i think that's what brought the five
of us together
um you know along with my partners uh
bill and chris and corey and kim
um
that we
that was how the conversation started we
didn't join each other because we all
had a sort of
similar hand or aesthetic idea we had a
conviction that the practice could be
better
and then joined by our other partners
and our incredible staff i think people
are attracted to us who want to have
those questions so it was there from day
one
it was there from the first day i walked
into architecture school that i just
wanted to know why the city was the way
it was and i think we all felt that way
and wanted to learn more about how to
have an impact on it
so it was it was day one
i didn't know what i was talking about
but i it was day one
i probably still don't
no you do good job
[Laughter]
uh
no avi you're an editor you can't joel
you had your time to talk to him
[Laughter]
after hearing
tonight's exquisitely crafted lecture i
forgive you for canceling our meeting
yesterday
i was told first thing at nine o'clock
in the morning meetings cancelled and
then i heard from a reliable source
greg's in a panic he's working on his
lecture that is correct
and so clearly i know why because i set
up i set aside two weeks in august to
work on it and so i got to it yesterday
no but but clearly it shows and i think
one thing that
i think impresses is that it seems very
perfectly calibrated to talk to this
audience that that you know of students
and peers and so i guess my question is
would you give this same lecture to some
of the other constituencies the
politicians the
uh the fabricators the developers i mean
one of the takeaways is that we have to
be nimble and talk
how do you craft and alter
this lecture to speak to good question i
mean i don't really get the chance to
lecture to you know government officials
that often but many of the i mean if you
want to say that when you're doing a
community board meeting or something
when you're trying to convince a
community to do a building these are the
same images they might be in slightly
and the same diagrams they might be in
slightly different order and the the
the inside baseball information might be
removed but in general we're talking
about trying to make cities better and
we're trying to talk about what the
risks are and what we think can improve
it and what they might have to trade for
one thing or another and why we think
that the trades we're proposing for them
are good
and we might say that to a fabricator
and we might say that to a client it
wouldn't be exactly the way it's phrased
here for an architecture audience and i
think that's a problem that architects
often have is that they forget how to
talk to a general population or to a
specific other population we're so busy
talking to each other
and it's uh it's important to you know
to to to learn how to speak to many
different groups so i'd say 80 percent
of the information is the same and 20 is
crafted a little bit differently
that's a good question
i'm reminded of something that jack
roberts in the architecture you know
and many in the audience do i hope he
told me a very long time ago when he
left
practice and
worked for the city and then he went to
work for a developer
and he said he learned one thing at the
developers meetings
at the table all the people at the table
the lawyers everybody were arguing for
more money and the architect was arguing
for a lower fee constantly
now he was speaking tongue-in-cheek but
it is true oh i'll be so happy to do
this project mr developer right or
whatever uh architects have had a very
bad sense of what their value is and
they think it's not that if you get paid
in a capitalist society you're
compromising yourself and i i'll make an
argument it's exactly the opposite
absolutely and we should and you know
what
we all have such respect for the academy
we have such respect for theory we have
such respect for institutions like this
and and it's very very important but i
also think for these institutions to
thrive we have to have these
conversations as well it shouldn't be
all about money the way or 80 of our
money the way it is in practice
sometimes but but why not talk about
this on day one and think about how we
can all do this better it's good for all
of us
maybe one more question if there is one
if not
i think we will
do what
good
hard-earning
high-earning architects do
drink
thank you
[Music]
you